because most people have adapted and
they're like I have these tools to
communicate directly with fans and then
you have this really elite sanctum of
Hollywood this really elite group of
people they don't speak ever unless
they're at a red carpet or they're you
know it's a very staged production where
they go on Jimmy Fallon or they go on
Seth Meyers and they sit in the chair
and they have five minutes of banter and
it's like well hey I you were in Italy
recently and there's nothing real about
it you know you were in Italy you know I
was in Italy when you weren't Italy you
love when they do that when somebody
will be like remember remember when we
were both in Italy it's it's so insane
that this even still goes on and the
lead-in to these shows is like you know
a mass shooting or you know a senator
who's been found to be taking a bribe or
some scientists at Harvard who got
caught sneaking biological samples to
the Wu Han Province of China which no
one really talks about and then then we
we go to Jimmy Fallon and Seth Meyers
who want to talk to somebody about the
time they were both in Italy it's crazy
you got to look at some old late-night
shows where guys like James Baldwin the
famous black intellectual go out and
talk about real [ __ ] they talk about
real stuff but these late-night shows
they're their viewers are falling
they're decreasing steadily and they're
terrified of upsetting anybody they're
terrified of losing a fat housewife from
Galveston Texas who thinks it's fun that
Jimmy Fallon plays with Muppets every
night and that he sings with the band
and he does dances and he brings out the
kid from stranger things and they play
hopscotch or whatever the [ __ ] they do
I mean it's imagine watching this and
having a real job
imagine having a real job we're like you
working the factory and a guy next to
you is like I just got diagnosed with
cancer I don't know what to do and you
go home and you put on Jimmy Fallon and
he's playing a game with Zac Efron or
he's going to the Olive Garden with post
Malone like it's the crit so that's
where these celebrities that's the only
time that they ever communicate with
peoples on these like late-night shows
which are
like a dystopian nightmare reality in
which insanely wealthy people sit there
and have meaningless convert like
meaningless conversations beyond the pit
now if I'm asked to do panel and I have
to say this I do have to I have to be
clear about this if I'm asked to do
panel in one of these shows I will I
don't think I think I'm beyond where I
should be doing stand-up in a 5-minute
said so so my stand-up doesn't really
work in 5-minute little bits and I don't
I can't do it if I can't say what I want
to say and I you know years ago we
submitted to do stand-up on these late
and I chose and they go it's too ranchy
and it's too dark and I was like you're
right you're right and I'm good with
that like I I love my friends who do it
I love what Norman does it I love when
Sam Morril doesn't I love what I watch
people do it I don't need to do it I'm
not bitter and angry everything's fine
but if they want to talk to me on panel
um I will do that now here's what will
also happen that episode won't air
that's also gonna happen because I it's
not gonna air because I will ask them
what they're doing like I will look at
one of them as I'm sitting there go let
me ask you a question what are you doing
like what in God's name are you doing um
I mean I know this pays well but I will
just keep bringing up real [ __ ] and
there will be censored because you got
to realize the people that go to these
shows like the people that attend
imagine going to New York City the
greatest city in the world in my opinion
um and and and I'm right but imagine I'm
in London's a goth nightmare the food
sock shut up Shanghai that'll have its
time it's coming don't worry about it
you'll have the next century let me have
the past one thank you imagine going to
New York City with a group of your
friends group of your friends the great
restaurants the great public spaces all
the things you can do the museums and
having one of them go I'd really like to
watch a taping of The Tonight Show
tonight I imagine being on a trip with
someone that said that and just the it
would be like you did the just feeling
in the pit of your stomach of a doctor
saying positive to you that's
feel like to me of a doctor telling you
that you you had AIDS you know not even
a it's something even worse than that
like just you have six months to live
we're sorry inoperable the word taping
of The Tonight Show to me is synonymous
with the word inoperable like be hearing
it's inoperable
because if I mean can you imagine
hearing that from somebody like I want
to go to a taping of The Tonight Show
tonight why why would you ever want to
go see a thing that you can see on TV
and you could watch it on TV and
shouldn't but what in God's name you
don't know who the guests are they're
all like who knows who it's gonna be
it's gonna be exciting we're gonna see
Jimmy's gonna come out maybe I'll have a
field piece Lord goes to the Olive
Garden with post Malone or cardi B and
they can sit in the Olive Garden where
people have worked 16 hours to make a
living and and they soak their feet
every night because they swell because
they're on them all day and they're
taking amphetamines to just to just keep
doing it and keep [ __ ] answering the
questions that fat tourists from Ohio
have about penne alla vodka they they
have to do that and they're all drugged
up and they can barely have a cigarette
break and when they do they go outside
it's just a cacophony of New York City
blaring horns and ambulances and they go
back into the Olive Garden and then they
have to hear from their manager that
well you got to look good today because
Jimmy's coming in with post Malone now
I'm sure that there are some people that
enjoy this and work in the alcohol
because they're so broken they've been
so destroyed in every possible way that
some of them might get excited maybe
they're young kids but there's got to be
a guy that considers having a Travis
Bickel moment there's got to be there's
got to be a guy that thinks of throwing
a tour of Italy on the table and then
lunging and falen there's got to be one
of those chefs in the back that's had
quite enough of this [ __ ] what is the
bit that the Olive Garden is good
it ain't that's the bit that rich people
do let's go eat this oh [ __ ] that
regular people eat and pretend it's good
whoo let's go to good no it's not it's
not good it's disgusting and everybody
who eats there hates everything you
believe in or say you believe in Jimmy
Fallon you know it's a repulsive
strong it is repulsive the Olive Garden
is there's no quality about it in New
York City you could get anything they
serve they're better in a pizzeria and
they go to the Olive Garden and I guess
the joke is like we're taking cardi B to
Red Lobster we're gonna teach you how to
use silverware I don't know what the
joke is that she's like what's Ritz
cocktail and you have to explain it
what is the bit I've lost on the bed I'm
really truly lost on the bit but imagine
someone suggesting so this is why these
celebrities and the people that rise to
that level are so insanely disconnected
because they're only showcased to us on
that show or on a show like the view
where they go out and it's just five
women screaming about politics and then
a celebrity comes on to promote some
movie of the week that they're doing you
know I mean it's it's it's it's truly
crazy I want to hear a podcast from
these people
where's Margot Robbie's podcasts I want
to hear Emma Stone's podcast you know
Emma's having panic attacks she's it's
too debilitating panic attacks that
she's suffering I feel bad for her I
don't like anxiety but maybe you're too
rich and you're too white and you're too
pretty and you're too successful but it
doesn't fill the whole Tim it doesn't
fill the whole when you get all that
money and success it doesn't feel the
whole you're actually more upset good
suffer in silence shut up about it
shut up then I understand that I
understand that it doesn't fill the hole
I do things all the time to fill a hole
and they don't I got at but just enough
already we don't need a whole story
about this